so uh let's let's do this let's talk
about walk away okay because you you sat
down
and i said the shirt question sure
question
so uh you when you first got here i was
like you know normally what
what we like to do is we like to grab
like the relevant news stories that
might matter to you so we just had the
dnc it's kind of perfect you're here
we kind of had like an undnc week we had
carrie smith she's liberals for trump we
had jack murphy democrat deplorable and
now you're here
and then you were like you don't have to
walk away you you do
you have to walk away from yeah but you
said from the left and i was like
what i said was i i walked away from the
democrats i think officially
like april or something when i was like
i am done donating to these people
i donated to a few of these you know a
few of these democrats because i thought
we needed to try and
salvage you know find some people who
are challenging
the democratic establishment to make
sure the party doesn't fall
into you know the hands of the you know
the dark lord or whatever
right but then but then what happened so
uh look i think tulsi is great
and i donated to her and i was straight
up like tulsi is is the right choice
because
she's willing to bridge the gap with
trump supporters talk to tucker carlson
she's very anti-war i love it and then
she supported impeachment
although i think she ultimately
abstained or whatever she got snubbed
from the dnc go figure
they're not right you can see what they
what they do to tulsa and how they
treated her
and that they're not i don't think that
they can be salvaged at this point at
least
and then yang went right on board with
all this stuff too and i just felt like
the people that i thought i was going to
support who are going to try and push
back on the absurdity joined right in
the moment they had the opportunity and
i should have learned my lesson with
bernie sanders
you know bernie doesn't say millionaires
anymore no bernie sanders used to say
the millionaires and the billionaires in
this country and then guess what
happened
what he became a millionaire oh right
and then all of a sudden he just started
saying
the billionaires yeah yeah because all
i'm like dude you can be a millionaire
and still call out
extreme wealth and influence in politics
no he got right on board he's supporting
hillary
you know he supported her he supported
biden and i was like what is this right
he was supposed to be the honest guy and
i believed in him
and then i remember this moment on the
debate stage when when bernie said if
you're white you don't know what it's
like to be poor
and that for me i was like excuse me
dude i was like
i'm from the south side i thought this
guy cared about working-class people
right outside of chicago i thought he
cared about working-class people
i thought he was fighting for you know
help like unions and
and these these traditional values that
the democrats are supposed to support
and then he had the nerve to get up
there and say white people don't know
what it's like to be poor live in a
ghetto
one someone i grew up someone i knew
when i was when i was a teenager
died of a heroin overdose other people
have been shot and killed
and guess what they were white they
certainly knew what it was like to live
in a ghetto and i was extremely angry
bernie sanders said that
then when he lost he went endorsed
hillary and i was like get out of here
it's exactly the problem fool me once
fill me twice fill me thrice it's just
gonna keep happening so i didn't vote
for anybody
but now i'm angry yeah for a lot of the
reasons you probably said
look i worked for this media company
they told me to lie
they didn't explicitly say hey tim go
lie they said side with the audience
i asked if that means that there's a new
story
that would be offensive to our ants we
don't we don't report it and they said
yes
that's fair so what does that mean that
means if you're watching a fight between
anti-fun say the proud boys
i better not let the audience know that
the proud boys were only defending
themselves
because that would offend the audience
yes so then what do we report antifa was
viciously attacked by a proud boy right
that's how everything plays out and i
said no to it they put me in gold in
handcuffs the money was great but i
couldn't do anything
ended i was out i started my own thing i
actually went to a bunch of these other
companies
after i left it was called fusion it was
abc news and univision joint venture
i went to a bunch of the new york
companies they all knew me they all
loved me
and i saw what was going on in those
offices i saw these people who were
lying on purpose for money
that were playing dirty games and i said
appreciate the offer
and i left aren't a lot of them also
there for kind of altruistic reasons and
have their hands tied themselves that
they're kind of taking orders from the
top about what they're supposed to
what the narrative is or what they're
supposed to be saying they don't want to
actually be doing it
no not at all the the way it works is
that
they would never hire you because they
know what you say yeah
they hire people who say who already
talk the way they want
right it's it's it's just that simple a
lot of people seem to think that these
journalists are being forced to do it
no no the journalists don't want to do
it quit or get fired
and then they hire people they'll ask
him in the interview how do you feel
about trump oh i can't stand them
well this is a tech reporting here
you're hired exactly
and and that's how it rolls wow so
here's the question i had you said walk
away from the left though
i mean i can rag on democrats all day
and night sure i don't see my political
opinions changing
for the most part i will say with all of
the chaos and destruction in a lot of
these cities
at this point even though my my policy
ideas and opinions
some of them are are pretty you know
deep seated
because i've thought really hard about
certain issues um you know freedom
pro-choice taxes and things like that
but
i'm willing to give the republicans a go
of it in big cities because the
democrats have completely failed yes
they're corrupt beyond recognition at
this point right i mean you look at the
big cities
and it is it i mean there's bill de
blasio
giving his wife a two million dollar
staff meanwhile he's gonna lay off
emts it's like i get it man a two
million dollar a year staff isn't gonna
pay for every single emt but you can
hire a lot of them
nope nope my wife needs these people to
film her bait cookies
then you look at garcetti in l.a what's
he doing he says we're going to shut
your power off if you have a peaceful
assembly right that's that's
unconstitutional and a violation of
humanity it's just a peaceful assembly
if you have too many guests over to your
house
well that's what it is a piece of
peaceable assembly it's the first
amendment yeah the constitution doesn't
say what you can assemble for it says
you can assemble period
yeah but we're talking about indoor
we're not even talking about in a public
place or a public venue i mean
like i i'm not allowed to get
coronavirus if i want to
at somebody else's house like that's not
my choice anymore
well look i can understand wanting to
prevent
covet for sure and it seems like we had
a really big problem earlier this year
and it was kind of it was kind of scary
these these fraser trucks in new york
city
a lot of bodies being pulled out italy
brought in the military to bring bodies
out it seems like we did get hit by
something
and it seems like it's mostly mostly
gone mostly herd immunity
to be fair i understand we're locked
down and the reason
we may still be seeing very little
uptick is because we are locked down
but to me we were told 15 days to slow
the spread not stop cover which means
these cities these states you look at
south dakota
they're having a great time barbecuing
they threw a parade for their governor
their gdp is improving she act christie
gnome rejected
the the stimulus that trump you know the
executive order stimulus because she's
like we don't need it
are our people are back at work now i
get it's not you know as population
dense as say new york
but new jersey's arresting people right
still yes this is this is insanely
corrupt insanely corrupt well there's no
acknowledgement either that
new new york new jersey i mean the vast
majority of the people who died died in
nursing homes
i think i think it's like 40 something
42 yeah yeah yeah
yeah the plurality i suppose you know so
so
what do you what what is what do you
mean when you tell me to walk away from
the left though
well you kind of just started to
transition into i guess what i would
have
said is that you know a lot of people
say people have a lot of opinions
about obviously about what i do and some
of the things that people say to me is
that you know you've gotta
you've gotta distinguish the difference
between a liberal and a leftist it's not
the same thing people say it's true
okay maybe yeah okay actually i can get
on board with maybe that that's
not true however i was just having this
conversation i think last night with
somebody else
um i make the analogy of black lives
matter
okay which is pretty apt these days so
there are black lives matter protesters
that are peaceful
for sure uh there are a lot of black
lives matter
rioters and people who are out
committing acts of violence vandalism
have murdered people um and
somehow i'm expected to distinguish the
difference between the two
or i'm expected to take someone at their
word when they say
well yeah some of the people are doing
that but i'm one of the good ones
or or or that you know we we somehow
have to
just acknowledge that it's a big
movement some of it's bad some of it's
good let's ignore the bad and let's just
focus on the good
it doesn't work that way for me it
doesn't work that way whatsoever and i
apply the same exact logic
to the left in general i don't want to
hear
about how you're one of the good
liberals and that you're not like the
other people from the same party or the
same
sort of ideology that you uh consider
yourself to be a part of because
once you have people in your political
movement
who are beyond just race-baiting beyond
telling lies beyond
creating narratives in the media that
are so divisive and destructive but are
actually out
looting stealing shooting burning things
to the ground destroying
cities people killing people you name it
i
i'm not going to sit here and play this
game with you but i'm a
i'm a good liberal i'm not a leftist i'm
a get the hell out of there dude
hold on hold on hut and run liberal
means something
and it's been really corrupted by
everybody over certainly lives matter
means something
it absolutely does so if someone was
a white nationalist and they called
themselves a con conservative i could
apply similar logic well i'm not going
to listen to you as you try and tell me
you're one of the conservatives who's
not on board with that you know fringe
ideology
so it it doesn't it doesn't work that
way you know what i mean
well unfortunately though with the
example that you named we're talking
about like
65 million voters
and like a few thousand that are
actually white supremacists or white
nationalists or whatever and i don't
believe that the discrepancy is that
great
in the black lives matter movement or
liberals in general i think you're right
i do
i think you're right especially with
that argument there's substantially less
white nationalism's premises relative to
the bulk of the conservative voting bloc
in this country right
so so i hear your argument i just it
kind of i i don't want to give up
what liberalism literally is but you
don't have to
you don't have to that's the thing you
know i uh
my values haven't changed whatsoever
with the exception of a few policy
issues which
might be a really big deal to some
people uh
you know things like the border i've
changed my opinion completely about a
border wall border security or illegal
immigration in general
i i would have been for it before and i
now i'm not
but you know even even bernie was
talking about building border barriers
and dealing with illegal immigration
back you know 10 12 years ago right
chuck schumer nancy pelosi they all
were right and and uh hillary clinton
said we need a border barrier
right so for me when trump came out the
wall i was like and
it's just with the democrats and then
also the democrats opposed it right
i think a wall is a little stronger than
a barrier and that's where they were
just like well it was fine when it was
you know a barbed wire fence that they
could
crawl over and that well but then when
trump actually builds bollard fencing
they complain
well he was supposed to build a wall
what do you care for you know
yeah that's the funny thing about the
wall yeah you know very early on trump
was prototyping out these big concrete
walls
and then ultimately ice was like well we
need to be able to see through it
and he was like oh so we should do
fencing yeah but we'll do multiple
layers and we'll reinforce these select
areas and he
he did the right thing there they yelled
at the man because he wanted to build a
wall he ultimately said okay we won't do
a wall we'll do select bollard fencing
triple layers and key areas to reduce
smuggling and trafficking
and now they're laughing saying ha ha he
never built the wall right well you were
you you didn't want them to
right what you meant about you know it's
funny because they always say that
conservatives just want to own the libs
but of course the libs just want to own
the cons
it's the same same game but you don't
have to give up
your your values and i mean maybe
there's a few examples you could name
that
do fall in opposition to republicanism
or conservatism
so this this this country if you look at
the actual philosophy of liberalism
it's it's republicanism and it's
liberalism together they're
complementary
republicanism in the sense that we have
elected leaders from various areas with
with
you know different jurisdictions we are
a constitutional republic we use
democratic
uh a democratic election process for our
representatives and the country is
founded upon
liberal ideals not liberal the way it's
been construed today though i'm talking
about classical liberalism sure
so for me i guess it's fair to say the
way we describe
liberals in this country has been wrong
for a really long time
what the democrats used to be at least
for a brief period was social liberals
you have social liberals and classical
liberals
social liberal describes me very very
well a center left
i believe in real social justice which
is like the civil rights act
there the left is trying to get rid of
it so it it seems like
i've noticed one thing a lot of
conservatives you know even trump will
say the liberals the liberals
and i'm like it's it's not like the
people who believe in liberalism
like even even social liberal social
liberalism not classical liberalism
mostly agree with the conservatives it's
the leftists and the people who who are
lying and stealing that name
or the p i mean look antifa spray
painted on the wall liberals get the
bullet too
many of these people hate liberals the
progressives
they they don't like liberals either
they make fun of liberals every day
because center left is not far left
enough for them
so what's really fascinating to me is
conservatives will talk about liberals
and you know slam liberals and all that
stuff
and then on these antifa forums i love
it when they make fun of me because they
call me a liberal
they know i'm not a conservative but
these weirdo resistance types who are
trying to push for biden in the
democratic party
hate the fact that i am and so they call
me conservative it's just not true
anti-fun the far left they know i am and
they hate me for it
so i i don't want to give up you know
the real
i feel like you're having an identity
crisis right here before our eyes
i feel like it's all happening because i
think that
what they i don't think that they hate
that you're
a liberal and they're not left enough
for them
i think that they hate that you are a
conservative so i'm not now
i have a question you mean one second
but are you saying that conservatism has
changed well conservatism has become
much more
uh socially liberal uh i think that the
biggest thing that
issue that i would not be a conservative
today if people were still
uh homophobic or if there was a lot of
bigotry
and there are certain denials uh on the
right that bother me sometimes i have
people come up to me and they say
we were never homophobic i'm like give
me girl
give me a break come on uh but the thing
is
it's just not like that anymore there
are not that many people who
care the thing that they're not gonna
budge on well and that's not even true
either i was gonna say abortion
um there are many conservatives now who
will say look up until three months
i can live with it but the democrats you
know life begins at kindergarten at this
point they're
you know they're like oh right you can
abort up until you know right before
preschool registration uh and it it's
gone way way way too far so it's just
this is common sense yeah here's the
problem i have a lot of
you know generic wedge issue values that
are aligned with social liberalism
um i do think there's such thing as
systemic racism i think that the left
will not tell you
the truth so we can't actually have real
conversations about
problems in this country and ways to
solve them because they want socialism
and they're manipulating our emotions
around racism and identity to get what
they want
sure so i actually do like social
programs i'm pro-choice there's a lot of
things where i'm like
this is you know always where i've been
and i've thought really really hard
about these things i didn't just
make it up one day the issue i take is
if i just say you know what
conservatives have become more
encompassing
and you know like the things you said
about social liberalism and these
are socially liberal in certain ways
what happens then
is if someone like me just starts saying
that you know
like a person like me is conservative
then the wheel is turning in favor of
the left
that means they are taking the reins and
turning their fringe cultist ideology
into mainstream
when people like me give up where we've
always been
because i am not a conservative yeah i
take all these tests i am central
i am left libertarian pretty pretty
decently left libertarian
um i do have strong moral foundations
across the board so
it's it's it's a very center left i i
took the hidden tribes test
that one says i'm a traditional liberal
and i i
another test says i'm an uh left-leaning
independent
if i just say okay fine you know what i
give up i will be on that side
then the wheel rotates and the and the
far left moves closer
to mainstream center and i refuse to let
them take the middle of the overton
window
see that okay that's very very
fascinating to me
so it sounds to me like for you the
battle
if we draw a line down the center right
here's everybody on the center and the
right
you feel like the battle is here whereas
i feel
first of all i feel like i was pushed
over here
against my i didn't even against my own
volition right
um but regardless now that i am here
to me the battle is here versus here it
doesn't
and maybe there is a microcosm over here
but i think
there's a larger battle i mean we're
talking about our our country and our
culture and our
you know it's it's heavy big stuff and
this is again why i think i didn't
necessarily become a republican
because i think republicans are so
awesome and like this is the party i
can't live without
i became a republican uh as a defense i
think
against how far french the left is going
i think that if there's any hope of
riding the ship excuse the pun
uh we have to vote red
i agree i have to that i agree on yeah
um
the thing the things that bother me
about republicans uh
it's it's more administrative
administrative and organizational than
it is
policy necessarily i've seen with my own
here's an example
uh in in not even two and a half years
i created a movement and there's
literally hundreds of thousands of
people who
have joined this movement left they've
made testimonials they've written
stories they've made videos we have them
there's proof
i have never received a phone call from
anyone in the rnc like
love what you're doing how how can we
connect on this like
nothing yeah i mean it's like i don't
exist and
um there's no there's no organizational
power right now the left would be like
that's because they hate you because
you're gay and it's like no
no that's it has nothing to do with that
i think that they're completely out of
touch
with what's going on on the ground
because it's not just me that i agree
with there
there is a number of incredible
activists who are doing
amazing work i promise you none of them
will be featured on the rnc convention
this coming week
um i probably won't either and
um and and not that it's about the
exterior because republicans don't
really care about the exterior and i
don't care about the exterior
but we have amazing black brown
lgbt people who are doing incredible
work like just over
sin really since trump got elected
because it trump really created this
earthquake
that shook a lot of people awake myself
included but it's like the republican
party they are they're not getting
the gift that's being given to them
right now of all of this
all you know all of these amazing
activists and all of this you know
excuse the term
diversity that's kind of coming their
way
i think that they just kind of have this
idea that oh well let's just keep you
know fall you know playing by the same
playbook and hope for a different result
the left that's been taking over the
democratic party are the organizers and
the activists yeah they know exactly
what to do they have strategies they
have plans they have media manipulation
strategies i've i know many of these
people from you know background occupy
wall street
many of them aren't as active but i know
people who explained their propaganda
their strategies
there's one really obvious strategy they
they will throw a rock at a cop
and then when the cop swings back they
press record the where they publish
the cops swinging at people of course
that's just very very obvious stuff
it works yes republicans don't know this
game
and a lot of the people who came out for
trump who've never been involved in
politics before
don't know any of politicking and how
these dirty games are played
so what ends up happening and we've
definitely talked about this on the show
before
you've got these accounts run by
leftists and they direct people to take
action
so let's say you know you are seen in
this video
on an airplane not wearing a mask all of
a sudden these high profile
accounts with hundreds of thousands of
followers send a message out to
everybody
send this email to american airlines a a
gets inundated with 50 000 emails saying
ban this man from the flight right and
then they do and then they do
conservatives don't have those things
right because
a combination of not being hardcore
activists many new trump supporters not
being in the political world and they're
also individualists
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode